foreign
got another one just just came in we
didn't know it's like I was wondering if
it would be kind of slow because it's
like a holiday weekend I mean at least
if you're in the United States I don't
know if like other countries probably
but it's Memorial day tomorrow so I have
the day off work so I don't have to like
[__] get up early which is nice and
uh you know so three day weekend so I
kind of figure a lot of people do and
maybe they're doing barbecues and [__]
like that you know yeah so and they
don't want to listen to us talking about
[__] like we usually do yeah but you
know what I mean but but yeah I could be
better with their families I don't know
yeah so maybe it's that she has soaps
out hiking with her sister and
future brother-in-law so she's like
outside and stuff yeah
she I said are you gonna be sleeping
outside she's like oh no no we're gonna
leave a hotel
like we're not that serious yeah I was
like yeah all right it's like yeah we'll
go walk around outside for a little
while but then we're gonna go sleep in
an actual bed with some actual air
conditioning yeah that's more my speed
all right so my boy zanada The Desert
Fox
[Laughter]
he uh been sending some real good movies
lately yes indeed he's not Bad
Lieutenant King in New York
a [__] ton of them what else did he send
send a lot of stuff but this he's
recently he sent two more
both guy Richie movies yeah Lock Stock
and Two Smoking Barrels and then he sent
uh snatch snacks which is Guy Richie's
second movie this is Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels is actually guy Richie's
debut film yeah so we saw this movie
watched it last night I had seen it
before but you would never see I had
never seen it
um it's good it's kind of like
the train spotting of [__] British
gangster movies
taking place in the 90s I remember
seeing the trailer for this when it came
out
with the some dude with the damn brand
gun yeah yeah I remember that that thing
that's in the movie
I there was I liked the movie there were
some times where I couldn't follow it
because of the [__] British English I
was like wait hold on what I had to like
sometimes had to like Translate
viewings I'd get it you know what I mean
but I enjoyed the movie enjoyed the
whole thing you know it's
that's a gangster flick uh they're not
all good gangsters some of these guys
are just really shitty ass just to get
out of me which is funny you know that's
where the comedy element comes in it's
it's classified as like a cry a crime
movie but also like a dark comedy yeah
uh you know what I mean it's got an
All-Star cast and British actors and
guess what
sting shows up lingam and everything
trying to end up in the Yanni well we
were laughing about that because the
other movie that xanada sent us that we
just reviewed uh last week or whatever
and that also had unexpected sting
because uh his he didn't actually show
up in person but like his song was on
the end credits yeah but this one now
there's a reason I didn't know this
until I watched the um behind the scenes
documentary it was like an hour long
behind the scenes documentary
and the reason why sting is in the movie
is because his wife Trudy produced this
movie and she actually got it made I
mean she actually got financing for it
and got it distributed
um and [__] like that so you know and
made us a substantial um investment in
it and because I mean it's crazy to
think about nowadays because so many of
the people in it are super famous now
like Jason Statham and Vinnie Jones yeah
stuff like that it's the earliest Jason
it's his first movie this was his first
name he stands out he stands out in the
movie is like oh man that dude he's
something special yeah but he's like
yeah this was his first film and so
because there were quote unquote a bunch
of like relative nobodies in it yeah
Trudy was like says to her husband
staying well presumably while she's
floating over his lingam that um that um
well you know maybe it needs a little
bit of star power so why don't you be in
it like you know because everybody knows
who you are so she convinced him to like
do kind of a cameo he's not in it a lot
but he's in like a few scenes you know
what I mean so that's the reason why
sting is in it because his wife and
there was like extended um interviews
with her where she was talking about it
she said I'm not entirely sure like how
it happened but she got hold of the
screenplay because the screenplay was
kind of floating around and I guess she
was interested in producing film
projects and stuff and she read it and
she said well it wasn't presented really
well she's like it was just riddled with
typos and it just like looked real
shitty you know what I mean like real
unprofessional because like guy Richie
he didn't go to film school he didn't do
nothing like that and he was a little
bit of as they would say in the UK a
little bit of a tear away
um and kind of a criminal a little bit
um who better to write a movie like yeah
so a lot of the characters in this were
based on dudes he actually knew now the
funny thing about the Jason Statham
character you know when he's introduced
at the beginning of the movie and he's
just at this table in the street like
selling I think it's boxes of perfume or
whatever it is and he's given like a
spiel
um fun fact that's pretty much what
Jason Statham was doing in real life
okay when he was discovered by Guy
Ritchie from this movie
um because he was like he was out there
with his patter like stealing like
selling all the stolen [__] like he had
done some modeling I think too and he
was like a diver uh yeah it was like an
athlete and um but he's like yeah I just
saw this dude out there and he's like
and his patter was so funny yeah uh and
he was like so charismatic that he's
like oh man I want this dude in my movie
so he asked him so this was Jason
Statham's like first he's literally like
right off the street like in this movie
I was late to the Jason Statham game
I first saw him in um uh the the uh [__]
The Expendables yeah one two and three
and then saw him in the Meg
yeah that was a fun man that was a great
movie yeah they actually didn't the
sequel just come out not too long ago I
don't know is he in it I don't know if
he's in it okay but I think I remember
seeing a trailer for this we saw Meg in
the theater and we're like man this is a
good movie for such a shitty [__]
movie a giant shark movie yeah I mean
sharks are really scary and the movie
was like half Chinese too because it did
real well in China did you remember that
yeah yeah China invested in it was like
a half Chinese movie but it [__] it
was like All-American man the way even
though it's British guy yeah starred in
it it was great flick but uh no I was
late to the Statham game
uh now I understand it [__] crank one
[__] loved it we're just we're gonna
go see crank two we're gonna I'm I'm
dying to see that yeah
because like just the premise of it I'm
like oh my God that sounds ridiculous
and I love it
yeah so uh he's a great British actor
all right he does his thing he's plays
that kind of same role every time I see
him but that that's fine that's okay
he's working he's working and you get to
see him you know he's being Jason yeah I
mean
I think he's great man [__] uh
America appreciates it I'm not gonna put
him he's not gonna replace my [__]
boy Tom Hardy though all right Tom Hardy
can act this [__] ass off I love
everything I [__] loved I got I love
Tom Hardy got a [__] mad crush on him
for like an every Tom Hardy movie I've
seen a [__] super enjoy it especially
his gangster movie Legend yeah where he
plays Reggie and Ronnie Craig he's both
of them there's been a lot of movies
made about their friends but honestly I
think I mean there was one that was just
called The Craze that was also pretty
good but this one I think was better
yeah and Tom Hardy also plays uh [__]
Bronson who's like based it's a story of
a real life famous prison
essentially in the British prison system
it's called Bronson man if you haven't
seen those movies see them those other
British gangster movies this one is
right there with those movies it's the
crazy thing about this one yeah is that
this came out in 1998 and like I said
um from everything that I can I kind of
remember because I like I said I lived
over there for a little while and I was
going back and forth there a lot in the
90s and they love their crime films over
there they love their gangster movies
but a lot of people said you know there
hadn't really been a good British
gangster movie since The Long Good
Friday which is also a fantastic movie
by the way with Bob Hoskins and um they
said they hadn't really been a good one
since then or even really like a
significant one so when this came out I
mean this was kind of the first one that
spawned all of the like you know like
layer cake with Daniel Craig and like
all this other kind of stuff because
they said um this really like
reinvigorated British crime Cinemas so
all these gangster movies like sexy
beast uh you know which with railings
Ray Winstone was actually supposed to be
in this movie
um they had actually secured him I think
he was supposed to play uh Hatchet Harry
um and the the process of making this
movie like getting the funding for it
because initially they were gonna get
like 20 million pounds to make it and
then they said it just get kept getting
slowly whittled down a whittled down
until it was like 800 000 pounds like at
the end and so and they said it took so
long to get financing and to get made
and the casting and everything like that
that Ray Winstone
um couldn't do it anymore because he had
to go on to like another obligation like
another job and so he couldn't do it and
so they had to like kind of recast like
everybody and [__] like that but he was
actually supposed to be in it so yeah
Ray Winstone was in sexy beast but the
thing about it is that this was like the
first film and they said that the
British uh audiences they [__] loved
it 800 000 pounds I think this cost
which is about 1.2 million dollars in
American money and it made like 30
million and it was like top of the box
office like in the UK and [__] like that
and it was just like a cultural
phenomenon and it really spawned this
whole like I said a whole what is is the
word I'm looking for a Renaissance in um
British gangster films that were like
funny like dark comedy type of stuff the
movie in the way that it kind of the way
that the story's told the tone it kind
of reminds me of a darker version of
trains body uh which is another great
flick
imagine if train spotting was about
[__] criminals it's like that I mean
it kind of is but here's what it kind of
is about her but you know gangsters yeah
British gangsters it kind of reminds me
of that
um
it's got a lot of different kinds of
characters different ethnic groups
fighting you got like Jamaican British
gangsters against the [__] the Anglo
British gangsters it's good man it's
good I liked it it's a good flick I love
that one that one character's name's
Rory and he's like a like a Crime Boss
or whatever with the afro yeah and just
like the [__] that he says about he's
like is this some kind of thing that
like white [__] do that black cons
don't understand
there's so many [__] great lines like
this screenplay for this is so [__]
funny race and ethnicity is super
important in crime stories in in any
kind of gangster movies because
criminality manifests itself differently
in each one of these cultures all right
and each culture has different
subcultures in it too you know what I
mean so it's good you know like a
British gang says not like Mexican Mob
there's big differences the only thing
that unites them is that they're humans
you know what I mean there are you can
identify with them all I can watch it I
can watch gangster movies that come from
anywhere even saw one from Nigeria all
right it was [__] wild as [__] okay
but uh
you can identify with anybody it's just
the the differences is the the damn
culture that is happening in and the
rules that it's happening in and just
the lingo and what they think is cool
you know it's just it's good you know
it's just a good good storytelling you
know when it's done right Anthony
manduca recommends the limey which I've
also seen and you would probably like
that too that is also [__] great I
really like there's just it was such a
great run of like British crime movies
yeah I love [__] like that because well
I don't know I'm really a big fan of
British English like for some reason
it's a lot funnier to me yeah that you
know what I mean so if I like comedies
and stuff or comedians they tend to be
Brits because they just have a way with
words that a lot of Americans don't have
I can't really put my finger on what it
is but they just have like this really
creative way with language that I'm
really into and Americans don't do that
they just punch you
although a lot of people get you a lot
of people get punched in this movie as
well including a woman yeah
so yeah I mean what was actually like a
pretty hilarious scene because like that
woman who I think is pretty much the
only woman in the movie but um she's
like she's kind of like a stoner chick
right and she like basically sleeps
through the whole movie and it's like
she's so such an not entity that that oh
dude like sits on her like as he doesn't
even notice she's there he's like oh
didn't even see you their love or
whatever and then like just that one
crucial point in the movie she just like
picks up that [__] massive what a
like gun it just like starts blowing
everybody else it's a brand gun and then
the dude just walks up to her and where
did you come from wow it just like
punches her the [__] face oh my God
it's so great this was also the film
debut of Vinnie Jones
um the hilarious thing about this is
that how Vinnie Jones got because I you
know if you don't know uh he was
actually a soccer player or football
player if you're from the UK so very
very famous uh for that
and I believe prior to this movie he had
been like had a cameo appearance like on
a TV show or some [__] like that but
when guy Richie wrote the script for
this movie the the whole description of
big Chris which is the name of his
character
was
um a big [__] who looks like Vinnie
Jones you know the soccer player yeah
and so then they were like well we saw
Vinnie Jones on TV and we're like why
don't we just ask actual Vinnie Jones to
be in the movie and uh and he did so
this was and now he's actually he's been
in a [__] ton of stuff any Jones has he
just has a great look like the tall guy
right yeah yeah yeah like I mean pretty
much he can and the whole [__] was like
him and his son big Chris and little
Chris that [__] was like [__] funny I
could watch a whole movie about those
two yeah that they should do a spin-off
it's probably too late now but it's like
they should do a spin-off of like big
Chris's little Chris and the one scene
too where um you know where he slams
that dude's head in the door just like
over and over and he's just like losing
his [__] [__] I was watching a thing
where they shot that scene and they said
they weren't really sure what Vinnie
Jones was gonna do that day but they
said they had the cameraman in the car
and then they said they put like a plank
of wood like in the door so he'd have
something to Slam against because he's
supposed to be like I think it's um the
the character dog is supposed to be
supposed to be slamming his head and
then so they pull Vinnie Jones aside the
guy Richie does and he says I want you
to scare the [__] out of the camera man
and so basically he just goes and starts
[__] freak and he's like when he was
done with that scene it's like it was
just completely silent because he just
like [__] lost it and it's like it
was like super super scary and then like
that the the director and the editor is
like well I don't think we need to do
that over again do we it's like it's
just you know what I mean because he
just like he [__] killed it like the
first time around but yeah he was like
super super scary in that but so the
thing about this like you were saying
when we were watching this because this
is definitely a movie that
um you know if you're American and you
don't really have an ear for British
accents or British uh vernacular
you probably uh should put on the
subtitles that help I always do that
anyway because I can't hear that good
but um but it does help now I will say
that this I wouldn't call the story
convoluted necessarily it's very it's
Tarantino s that's what's going to say
in the sense that well and a lot of
people said that at the time they're
like oh he's like the British Tarantino
because where it has because it's like a
whole bunch of different stories that
like threads that kind of all come
together in the end whereas well
Tarantino's are more like threads that
are kind of like each doing their own
thing but they're sort of interrelated
and they kind of come together but this
one everything comes like all the
threads come together at the end but at
first like you don't really know like
where they overlap necessarily it is
kind of a complicated story so you do
kind of have to
um pay attention and a lot of people say
too I mean I've seen this twice I think
I saw it in the theater when it first
came out
um so this is like the second time that
I've seen it and a lot of people do
advise like you watch it more than once
because there's like there's a lot of
like stuff going on there's like a lot
of jokes and stuff that you might mix
like Miss like stuff that's set up at
the beginning that pays off later on
there's a lot of extra dialogue that
sounds ad-libbed that's good yeah just
add the character which is that I was
watching it and I was like is this
almost kind of like Tarantino where the
characters are just talk like talking
about Madonna or they you know right not
as bad if you ask me sometimes Tarantino
took that [__] too far because he's a
little self-indulgent but I'm not
[__] on tear I like Tarantino's
movies but I but sometimes he does
sometimes
so it never does that yeah the dialogue
always seems very natural which I like
that
and it always fit the character like
come on they're talking about Papa don't
preaching Madonna some of those dudes
were [__] far too old to be Madonna
far too old far too [__] mean to be
Madonna fans I guess it was supposed to
be funny
yeah that [__] old ball well yeah 60s
would be following Madonna right Papa
don't well yeah that's what it because
it's supposed to be like the the
incongruity of it is yeah due to that
generation
yeah [__] her you know I've been like
that you know yeah it'll never that'll
never bet you know that that'll never be
as good as the [__] you know Sinatra
you know or something that'd have been
like that yeah well speaking of Madonna
she was actually uh she married guy
Richie like later on yeah they were
married for like eight years yeah well
the funny thing about it she met him
after this movie came out because she
saw this movie and she really dug it and
she really particularly liked um the
soundtrack and she asked guy Richie or
like you know the production company or
whatever would you mind if because she
has her own record label Maverick
um and said we can we release the
soundtrack for this movie like in the
U.S so that's how um they ended up
getting together you're gonna love this
story though
do you know who was responsible for
getting Lock Stock into Smoking Barrels
a distribution deal in the U.S none
other than Tom [__] Cruz Tom Cruise
interestingly yeah this is a crazy story
okay so what ends up happening like I
said it opens in the UK and it went like
gangbusters like everybody's like oh my
God it's the best British crime movie
ever or since The Long Good Friday which
is that's another one we should probably
do a couple people are brought up snatch
too xanada also sent a snatch which is
the follow-up to this movie
um and so that's the next one we're
gonna do
um but yeah and that has Brad Pitt in it
and Brad Pitt actually liked this movie
so much that he called guy Richie and
said hey if you're making another movie
I'll be in it which can I mean that must
be [__] crazy for like a young
director like having Brad [__] pit
calling you but so what happened was uh
so the movie comes out in the UK it's a
huge success and
um Trudy who you know sings wife
she's sitting there talking about she's
like we weren't really having a lot of
luck like getting a distribution in the
U.S because like you know we'd have
screenings there and people like eh you
know what I mean it's like it's just too
British you know what I mean like they
couldn't really see that it was going to
be like successful or anything like that
and so she happened to be friends with
Tom Cruise and she said I guess her and
sting had like an apartment they owned
an apartment in the U.S somewhere and
Tom was staying in it at the time like
because he was shooting a movie like
wherever the city it was and so she
called him up and said hey I have a big
favor to ask of you we're doing a
screening of this movie that I produced
and we are trying to get like Executives
interested in it
um but we don't really think anybody
it's gonna get any traction can you just
go don't tell anybody you're going just
show up and watch the movie and they're
like just you being there we'll probably
be like holy [__] yeah so that's what he
did and basically she's like I'm sorry
but it's tonight like you have to go and
he's like okay I'll do it
um he's like not much you know he's like
he didn't give me much uh you know
Advance warning but okay I'll do it so
he goes just like on the down low and
watches it and then like after the
screening everybody so it's like oh my
God
Cincinnati they're all getting their
cell phones out and [__] like that and
he basically went up there and he said
oh my God this is like the bread the
best like um the breast movie the breast
there's no breasts in this movie but um
they didn't call you
no they did it they didn't call my
breasts to be in this movie because
because each of them has their own cell
phone yeah that's gonna be awesome
and only fans soon so the rest will be
there
well it's funny because we were talking
about both of them well I hope so we
don't want one to get jealous though
yeah yeah but yeah so he stands up and
then he says like this is like you know
the best movie I've seen like this year
like in a long time or whatever and you
guys would be idiots if you didn't buy
it so it did end up getting a deal I
think it was a polygram that ended up
buying it unfortunately it didn't really
do all that great like I think it did
make some money but it um basically it
got like really good critical uh reviews
and it got like something of a cult
following like even from the start so it
didn't like it wasn't a smash success
like it was in the UK but it did kind of
put guy Richie on the map you know what
I mean so then that was like largely Tom
Cruise's doing that did that but you
know they made money at other places too
so it wasn't
to you know and Guy Richie ended up
being I mean [__] he made like the
Sherlock Holmes movies and all that
other kind of [__] later on so he's like
a massive [__] success nowadays but
yeah what you were saying earlier about
the a lot of the dialogue being um
improvised some of it was but I was
watching a lot of the interviews with
the actors
and um you know they said obviously they
all got together and they all got along
really well and they all had a good
handle on their character and it's like
a lot of the stuff that's in there he's
like even though it sounds very
naturalistic it was all in the script
like that like guy Richie wrote it like
that but it's like but he was pretty
open to imp like if you wanted to
improvise something like Visa like he
would if he liked it he would keep it in
you know what I mean but a lot of that
they're like a lot of it it doesn't
sound like it but was written in the
script exactly as it was other than like
I think there was a couple there was a
little scene where
um where two that were Nick the Greek
and um and the other guy um [__] what
was that character's name Eddie no it
wasn't Eddie it was it was one of the
other ones but he was like um they were
standing at that like uh jukebox or the
cigarette machine or whatever and he
said something is like kosher is
Christmas and he's like oh the guy's
name was Tom I don't know why I didn't
remember that yeah but he's just like
Jews don't celebrate Christmas like I
think that was that [__] was ad-libbed
and like some of the other stuff was but
largely it was kind of written in the
thing like that it sounded like it was
pretty natural though like a result yeah
because I think like I said it was this
big ensemble cast and they said they all
got along really well like some of them
had known each other previously
and I think they just each had such a
good handle on
their characters that you know that they
just kind of did it all just kind of
like flowed naturally the funny thing
about it too is that the character like
the guy who played Tom he was like
originally the guy who played Nick the
Greek like the big heavy guy he was
supposed to be Tom because the running
gag throughout the movie is that Tom is
fat so he's like originally the actor
was supposed to be fat but then the guy
that they cast to actually play time at
then was this really tall lanky dude and
but they left all the fat jokes in
because they thought it would be funnier
because it's like obviously he's not fat
so it's like they had like a bunch of
jokes and there were people being like
what have you been eating son and it's
like they're like calling him fat and
stuff like that even though he's
obviously not fat and I'm just like yeah
that's that wouldn't have been funny if
the dude was facts it's like well yeah
obviously he's fat like so people are
just pointing that out but because the
dude was like obviously so much skinnier
than everybody else and everybody kept
calling him fat so I just thought that
was like funny and also the ending
because you said well they kind of left
the ending hanging yeah which they kind
of did but I like that now originally
the ending
um it did right where the gang like they
got all the money and then they drove
off in the car and then you know and
everybody's dead so they're like woo we
got away with it you know I mean because
everybody pretty much gets killed
spoiler alert but um you know so they
get the money and then like the it would
pull back and then you saw Vinnie
Jones's character big Chris and his son
little Chris in the car and they're just
like oh we're gonna go get that money
and then they were gonna follow the car
and then it was then it ended right
there
so they did some screenings with that
and there's like the audience didn't
like that they're like what the [__]
it's like it seemed like there should be
more story there like it just kind of
ended in the middle of nowhere so then
they shot the scene with
um them finding out like him like Vinnie
bringing back the bag and saying like oh
I brought this but there's no money in
there it's just like that book that says
how much those anti-guns were worth yeah
and then they had just told Tom hey go
get rid of those guns because that's the
only thing that ties us to this crime
and he's just like about to dump them
into the Thames and it's like the
phone's in his mouth and it's like
raining shut up it's rigging they were
too ancient like I think they were
Richard and Harrison or Harrison
Harrison what were they uh yeah Harrison
and Harris Harrison and Harrison yeah
um Fowler's [__] Hammer operated
[__] Fowler shotguns uh they were all
[__]
damascined and stuff you know engraved
and [__]
but uh
they were treating them like [__] too
they're being rough on them and
everything you treat them like gangster
guns because they didn't realize what
they were no it turned out you know when
they got the damn collector's book that
said what the value was it was they were
about a half a million dollars each yeah
like or like a quarter of a million or I
think it was like 300 000 pounds or
something like that like yeah one of
them was it went from 320
000 pounds to 700 and something thousand
pounds and they had two of them
yeah so about a half a million dollars
of [__] I think a pound was almost
two dollars back in those days in the
90s maybe a dollar seventy five so they
probably would have been about a half a
million 500 yeah thousand each and they
like I said they literally just sold the
guy they were gonna throw them in a
river in the Thames they used to go
throw them in there and he was just but
but like it fell on the on the ledge and
then he's like oh [__] like he's leaning
down again and then the phone rings and
it's in his mouth and he's like oh no
yeah like that I was like I thought that
was a great ending honestly I thought
that was super there's lots of [__]
british-isms about guns in them they
don't there are some good guns in there
uh the uh the Jamaican gangster what was
his name they got like a Spitfire he's
British as [__] though even though he
was fighting for the Jamaicans or
fighting with the Jamaican crew you're
the one with the afro yeah Rory Rory
yeah Rory breaker he had a stainless he
had a modern stainless Walther PPK uh
they just had basic stuff they came up
with an old World War II bread gun
three or three British you know
problematic [__] mags they were good
back in the days but they're just not
modern
um and they said things that people that
don't know much about guns think like
well a professional uses a knife you can
actually cut somebody up with this but
um guns are just for basically keeping
you know keeping somebody Frozen you
just point it and if they freeze and
they do whatever you say ah no and maybe
in Britain you can point a gun at
somebody and they'll just freeze but not
in America if you point a gut at
somebody they attack all right they
force you to shoot them
I got I've seen thousands of videos of
that you go on go on a channel called
police activity on YouTube and see how
Americans react when you point when
somebody points a gun at them they just
go berserk and you're forced to kill him
or just shoot them up to pieces you know
so uh no they're not used they're not
any good for that not here at least you
pull a gun gun on somebody you're gonna
have to shoot them
well the whole thing about the the
antique guns in this one like I said I
think that's why this story may be the
first time you see it like it seems like
kind of convoluted because for a long
time you're not really sure like how all
of these disparate plot threads are
going to tie together because the guns
don't initially have anything to do with
the main gang like at the at the center
of the story it's just Harry the hatchet
who they own uh you know or Hatchet
Harry or whoever like the guy that they
owe half a million pounds to actually
wants those guns and hires these two
idiots to like go steal them and because
the dudes are idiots they didn't realize
that they were like Antiques and so they
sold them to this other so when they're
buying guns for their Heist they just
buy these guns like not knowing because
they're like making jokes about it's
like wait did these even work you know
what I mean it's like people are gonna
laugh at me when I go yeah when I pull
it on Stephanie it didn't seem to have
any concept of of guns being worth
anything in terms of antiques well yeah
I mean like I said these are like all
kind of like working class yeah dudes so
it's it's like you wouldn't really they
wouldn't really think they wouldn't know
anything about antiques or anything like
that so it's just like so that I mean
and that was like inherently what was
funny about that situation is just to
them it just looked like an old gun they
wouldn't really think it was worth
anything my family's from Mississippi
and when my dad passes I'm going to
inherit a bunch of Confederate stuff a
Confederate gun cabinet all right
[__] there are some Confederate era
[__]
uh [__] um uh muzzle loading rifles
in there and you would think that stuff
is worth a lot of money the rifles yeah
they are a little bit but what's worth a
lot of money is a Confederate era toy
gun that my dad has it's only that big
and it fires a percussion cap it's a toy
gun for a little kid you could put a
real percussion cap from a real gun of
the back in those days and fire it and
it'll go wow you could even put a rock
or something in the barrel that would
shoot that that's how that's how kids
played back then all right uh that
thing's worth many many times more than
a real well
toys are always tend to be more not
always but they tend to bring more
auction because you know kids play with
them and they get beaten away so it's
like kids don't keep them they play with
them and they get broken so if you have
something that's like mint from that era
then yeah mint but it's usable right but
so so it's gonna be like it's worth a
lot of money because you know if you buy
like a really nice gun I mean obviously
gonna take care of that like that's an
adult would have it and they would take
care of it and pass it on maybe to their
next family or whatever so they realize
the value of it but a toy is just kind
of like a man you know what I mean
that's why people pay like all this
money for like old lunch boxes from the
80s and [__] like that and the gun
cabinet's worth a lot hand blown glass
and everything in the doors it was kind
of a common gun cabinet in the day but
the handmade
and it has uh some kind of Confederate
slogan on it I forgot what it said but
uh something or some other [__] Dixie
or
Dixie strikes down Union some [__] like
that they they said stuff but that's
worth money too I don't know how I'm
gonna get it here
well you know I can figure something out
yeah
but um yeah so something else in this
movie like another [__] repeating gag
that I thought was like really funny was
the whole thing with um Rory's glass
topped coffee table and like every time
Nick would come over like he broke it
and then like he kept like putting his
glass like glass down on it and it goes
through the thing and they said we that
wasn't originally in the script that
whole like running gag with the broken
coffee table they said that actually
happened because the coffee table
actually did break uh when they were
shooting the scene and they didn't uh
have time to like get more glass so they
said well let's just write it in where
we'll just make it like this running
joke where he just keeps like dropping
the [__] drink through that because
he thinks the glass is there and there's
also one great scene too and I didn't
even notice it until I was watching like
some clips of it over again where Rory
is like coming at the camera like
telling that guy I'm gonna kill you I'm
gonna get you notice like that whole uh
monologue that he gives and he like
actually steps through the [__]
coffee table that doesn't have a glass
top on it and it's like I didn't even
notice that when I was watching the
movie the first time but he's just like
walking he just like like it's the most
casual thing in the world he just like
steps through the [__] coffee table
without saying anything about it but
yeah I [__] love that so
so yeah I mean like I said I love
British movies British crime movies are
the [__] best I mean we we haven't
really we've done some but there's a lot
that I think you would really like that
you haven't seen like I said you
probably need to see layer cake
um because you like Daniel Craig and
Daniel Craig is in it and I remember him
being great and I think I saw that in
the theater too
um somebody mentioned the limey which is
which also [__] great that was a
great movie
um and maybe you like go back to like
some of the old ones like I said like um
The Long Good Friday Mona Lisa was good
too because uh Bob Hoskins was in that
as well but I remember really liking The
Long Good Friday and a lot of people
think that's like the best British crime
movie like ever made
so just makes me stand by British
actress man or Superior actors they're
[__] great thespians man oh [__]
seriously they do well and I really
liked like I said there's a there's an
hour-long documentary it's actually on
YouTube um if you're just making a block
second tooth making barrels and they
interviewed like pretty much all the
principal
um actors from this and they're all just
delightful people like I love that they
had Nicholas Rowe was in this who I
hadn't seen him in much of anything
since Young Sherlock Holmes like back in
the 80s yeah and he was in this as like
one of the weed dealers yeah because I
recognize him immediately because I saw
Young Sherlock Holmes probably like 40
000 times when I was younger and I take
the piss out of [__] sting but sting
is [__] very talented yeah I know
he's trying to get up in your
girlfriend's skirt with his language and
his tantric sex and all that I think he
was trolling back in those days there's
something about his face I don't think
he was all that enlightened [__]
[__] I think I think it was char if
he was trolling the American middle
class
uh but uh
he's he's a good real good actor and
he's good in this he doesn't have a big
part but when he shows up he's very
believable yeah it's like a cat like a
camo he's probably only in two or three
scenes he's like the dad of the of the
guy that loses the 500 000 pounds at the
beginning like leading to the whole
situation he thinks best work if you ask
me is like the bride real good and uh
Brimstone and treacle that was a [__]
man he's a great emperor that's a
[__] great movie I think we did
review it at something we review it no I
don't know maybe it'll go I mean I I
reviewed it for my thing like I I don't
know if I made a video about it but I
for sure like wrote a big long like
Brimstone in Brimstone and treacle he
plays a demon yeah a young Charming
demon who talks his way into your house
and tries to just talk
just talks his way into total control
over your [__] family he's a great
[__] move you haven't seen it see it
there's a couple of versions of it like
I said because I think we've talked
about this before but they did it on um
play for today or whatever it was it's
Dennis Potter uh if you know who that is
singing detective Pennies from Heaven
um but yeah and this but this was like
the movie version but there is another
version of this it has some of the same
actors in it that they did like for TB I
think it was the the guys I only saw the
movie version had staying in it the
great cast and he's just
he's kind of [__] up it's kind of it's
[__] up but in a weird way she's kind
of lovable because yeah
he's very charming and you know he's
[__] this family over and he's doing
it he's a demon he can't help it he's
not a human he's just like a parasite
just trying to talk his way in to your
[__] you know what I mean
you're not sure I was I wasn't sure is
this guy just a con man no paranormal
[__] happens too he's a dick well like I
said in the this was originally it was
originally written as a stage play and
in the stage play it's very obvious he's
a demon because he has cloven Hooves
okay yeah but in the movie you can't
really you're not really sure they leave
it ambiguous as to like what his [__]
deal is like you're led to believe that
he's a demon but he just looks like a
person well storms would happen when
he's trying to molest the girl and the
molest this girl who's an invalid and it
snaps her out of her coma that's a weird
[__] it was some dude he was a demon
which like I said yeah he was a demon
and then as soon as he got out of the
house was expelled from the house he he
latched on to somebody else and at the
end of the movie yeah that's what he did
like a parasite
I always like it's like somebody you
would know it's kind of like people that
out of your life yeah I knew a dude like
that yeah couldn't get rid of his ass
you know he's like one of those they're
like extreme put that [__] up on 11. you
know since we're talking about sting we
should probably do Quadrophenia one of
these days I haven't seen it you've
never seen quite different yeah I
haven't seen it I really I like Audrey
yeah probably pretty good it's got mods
about mods in it yeah mods versus
rockers mods versus rockers yeah I'd
like to see that yeah yeah yeah they
were the original cafe racers the
Rockers yeah Sting plays what's this
character we call it bikers but yeah I
think it's what's his character's name
is Ace I think isn't it yeah he's the
one that they sing that song Bellboy
about yeah because he's supposed to be
like the coolest dude ever and then they
see him like working as a at a hotel as
a Bellboy like and they're just like oh
well he's not cool anymore because I
remember that that's like one one of the
main scenes that I remember from that
but uh but yeah so
so I yeah I feel like there's like a
whole unexplored thing of like British
crime movies that you would be really
into and so this is like I said there
was a lot of them like in the 70s and
80s and all of those are worth watching
too like all the ones that I've seen
I've seen a lot of them like I said
because I've lived over there for a
while but um this one Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels was kind of you know it
in the late 90s this was the kind of
thing that kicked off the whole because
now if you see ones like sexy beasts or
something like that with all that crazy
editing and
um you know just all the because this
like I said guy Richie didn't go to film
school so he was basically told like the
cinematographer or anything like that
he's like well don't worry about if it
like advances the plot or anything like
that like just if it looks cool shoot
that yeah like pretty much
um and the editor that he got was uh a
dude that did music videos and like
commercials and stuff like that so it
does have a little bit of like a music
video sensibility to it Parts I think
like in a lot of ways though I think
it's like fairly traditionally and it's
not like super frenetic or super I think
the editing got like much faster like
later on this one was pretty standard
but it did have some interesting
uh sequences like that were I guess
unusual for the time that were copied a
lot later on I also had some great music
and it had stone roses in it the Stooges
yeah um you know yeah some great [__]
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna sit I'm just
gonna repeat what I said in the in the
beginning of the review
it's a British gangster movie that's on
at the same quality level entertainment
level as trades body it's like the
[__] train spotting of British
gangster flicks it's a good foot it's a
great flick and it's funny I forgot how
[__] funny like a lot of the dialogue
it's not my favorite British gangster
flick I'm gonna get that I'm gonna give
that to Legend yeah but uh it's still up
there this is very respectable flick
yeah yeah and like I said I had
forgotten because I hadn't seen it in
such a long time but I'd forgotten how
[__] funny I mean I was just like
busting up like at some of the [__]
lines in this are so [__] great I had
forgot I remember this being good but I
didn't remember it being that [__]
hilarious like some of the [__]
[__] that they say and like some of the
well because the funny [__] comes from
them being like completely out of their
depth really and not really knowing
what's going on and it's like what I the
two guys I would also watch a movie
about the two uh scousers that stole the
guns and like didn't know they were
antiques like those two like the one
dude with the big floofy hair yeah that
gets like shot if I those two guys were
completely stupid and they were like
super super funny yeah all the gangsters
are of different
skill levels and different expert levels
of expertise right ranging from [__]
morons to dudes that are pretty comp
pretty common I mean most of they're
pretty small time and that's the thing
they're kind of going up against
somebody that's like a big like Crime
Boss and they think that they can like
well that's what I was gonna say
this is all happening within the theater
within the realm of British crime which
is not quite as ruthless as American
Crime this is not they're not as
ruthless as the Italian mob and nowhere
near as ruthless as the Mexican Mob
those guys are [__] top Echelon I
mean those guys are [__] mean you
know what I mean they're not that mean
they're by American Standards these are
Petty
gangsters Petty criminals but they're
they're just mostly stealing [__]
they're fighting each other they kill
each other but they're mostly just
stealing [__] and weed and
stolen trying to pass stolen goods and
[__]
that's petty crime by American Standards
over here
massive drug [__]
shipping human trafficking you know
enslaving women and selling them and
children too
cutting people apart while they're alive
and recording it you know it's like in
the Mexican Mob does not [__] play
all right they make a point that if you
come up against them it's a fate worse
than death and very effective very
effective it's just a different
situation there's still criminals that
are just in a different place you know
in a different culture and a good it's a
good flick though it's a good flick you
know well the thing I think the reason
why a lot of the British like crime
movies is because well and particularly
in their movies and not so much in real
life but um in their movies there's a
sense of like The Lovable Rogue yeah
about them they're kind of like regular
guys like if they just made a movie
about like horrible [__] that
was like cutting people it's like nobody
would root for that yeah and it's like
it wouldn't be funny or anything like
that so it's like kind of like heroic
underdogs yeah and I think that's kind
of why there's such been such a long
tradition of like British crime movies
where you know where they're almost kind
of like I don't want to say lionize
necessarily but a lot of people kind of
root for them like in the movies even
though technically they're criminals
yeah and even though technically
sometimes they kill people too but like
you said it's kind of like rooting for
the underdog because a lot of them are
kind of like
um you know maybe incompetent or going
up against
um forces much larger than them and
you're kind of like hoping that they win
the difference is between the criminal
cultures between Europe and and American
continent it was talked about and kind
of demonstrated in the other movie the
the my favorite which is the Tom Hardy
flick called Legend uh [__] one of
the cray Brothers the gay one tells the
the Italian mob that he likes to [__]
boys you know young guys he likes guys
and they don't know how to react to that
they tell you about they're not about
that okay but you see the British didn't
have that those kind of rules especially
that [__] was that Reggie or was
that Ronnie I can't remember which one
was though because he was just a nut
okay he just said he just constantly
told the truth he didn't he didn't Veil
the fact that he was gay but he was big
intimidating [__] and the
Italian mob was just like they weren't
sure if he was talented if he was
serious and they were like oh all right
you know what I mean but that [__] would
not fly in the United States with the
with the Italian not back then [__] no
no
I don't think he would have killed you
over it but they wouldn't have done
business with you yeah but they were in
England when they were talking to them
and they yeah they said they were like
they weren't really on their homes yeah
they weren't on their homes and they
were like okay all right if that's what
you like well and like I said maybe I
don't know because I kind of feel I mean
the British have like this whole like
culture surrounded like taking the piss
so a lot of the times you don't actually
know if they're being serious you're
being serious no yeah I'm thinking that
because a lot of because they're very
sarcastic but it's like you can't really
yeah I think in that particular movie I
think the Italians thought he was that
he was taking that he was talking with
them because they knew about that from
prison the Italians would know all about
that from like
prison
Mafia
it was a traditional honor-based type of
culture very family oriented right they
all had wives you had to be married to
be in the mob a lot of times and you
could have girlfriends but you had to be
married you had to have a family
uh and uh you had to be hetero there's
[__] you know there's no way you'd
ever get anywhere in the Italian mob if
you were gay [__] no they wouldn't deal
with you you would consider you to be
some human
they were catholic
yeah that was another they were catholic
yeah
Richard Brown said people used to admire
The Craze yeah they did that's what I'm
saying it's like I kind of feel like
there's a whole yeah I'm not so not so
much now I don't know like because like
I said I haven't been there in a long
time but I did kind of feel like there
was a through line through British
culture where they really liked
it's a little like I said Petty
criminals and even not even petticoats
like sometimes murderers and stuff like
that but usually gangsters they really
like I mean I guess you could say that
to be Americans too because it's like we
watched [__] movies about the Italian
mob and people love that [__] yeah yeah
you know and I don't know how much
people like admire those people I don't
think it's quite the same but I think
they did kind of I think people were
kind of envious of the freedom that they
had they were just yeah break laws and
free to do whatever the [__] they want
whereas I kind of feel like in the UK
like I said it was more like a lovable
Rogue thing like yeah like sticking it
to the Man type of situation
quintessential American Mafia movie of
course the Godfather series but more
modern I would the more modern version
would I would say would be [__]
Goodfellas that's that's a great [__]
The Good Fellas yeah good Fellas
be the the American version of a of what
this movie is this is there's a lot of
parallels between Goodfellas and this
one yeah it's a different tone but yeah
I mean this this movie yeah I mean it's
a good film I haven't seen Good Fellas
in a while but Goodfellas was great man
I remember this one being a lot funnier
than Goodfellas but yeah good Fellas was
kind of funny I thought that was a good
too though yeah yeah that's what we have
we we haven't reviewed no we haven't
seen it we did we did The Godfather
movies yeah but we haven't done good
anybody wants us to review I wouldn't I
wouldn't mind doing Casino
I really liked Casino yeah Casino was
good but if anybody wants us to do
Casino or Goodfellas he sent us the
Blu-ray we'll do it yeah but like I said
the next one xanadas sent us this movie
and Guy Richie's next movie which was
snatch
in which Brad Pitt like I said because
he liked this movie so much he straight
up called guy Richie and said hey I'll
be in your next movie
um because that's just what he does
apparently apparently he's done that
more than once like he said he likes to
go like especially if he sees like a
first-time director and he really digs
what he did like he will call that
person personally and be like hey I want
to be in your next project I'm like
that's kind of cool though you know what
I mean that's kind of cool that he would
do that like as famous as that Bridget
is that [__] so um in Snatch I don't
know if you know this
but he plays an Irishman okay
um it's pretty fun well
there was kind of a big joke because
it's like he's he has this crazy Irish
accent but you can't the joke of the
movie is you can't understand the
goddamn word that he's okay because it's
just got yeah you said and he's like a
crazy person you were talking about
um Angelina Brad Pitt and it reminded me
of [__] fight club that's another
Masterpiece man I want to see that one
again yeah now we did review that one we
reviewed it yeah I think I think I have
it Blu-ray
or did we read that
I think I have it I think we own it I'm
pretty sure we own it that was I don't
remember if somebody sent it to us or if
we bought it that was a masterpiece man
I think somebody sent it to us I'd only
seen it once I really enjoyed it I want
to see it again
uh Zach says oh my God please do Casino
I love that movie send us to Blu-ray
[__] I love that movie too I think I
saw that in the theater so we got paying
customers that have sent us Blu-rays
we've got a whole stack of them they're
in line so the only way we can guarantee
that we'll get to it is if you send us
the Blu-ray and then we'll put it in
live although I think we're caught up
except like the next one we have to do
is snatch because like I said that that
one came with this one like they both
came together and um so we'll do snatch
next because I've been wanting to
re-watch that one too I've seen snatch
as well but that it's been a while since
I think the last time I saw it was when
it came out because I'm pretty sure I
saw that in the theater because she
cranked two though yeah we also need to
see crank too and you know and honestly
it's
it's I don't know like because people
have been sending us movies too which is
awesome and so we're doing that I
definitely want to get back more into
doing like some more horror and stuff
too I mean I have been doing horror on
my other channels so I have that going
on too but you know because there's a
lot of new horror movies out that like
Renfield and stuff like that that we
haven't talked about today I mean we did
see terrifier too but we didn't do a
review of it yeah but it was I really
liked it it was like a lot better than I
was expecting I mean I was expecting it
to be good but it was a little bit
different than what I expected but it
was actually but that's a good thing you
want to send us a flash trap nah man
[__] just go on Amazon and [__]
buy it and it gets write us down as the
delivery is the delivery address just
send it here that's how we that's how
people are sending to us yeah
and stuff they just go on and then they
just just put our address put our
delivery address on it there it is and
this thing you can get them for a couple
bucks
10 bucks maybe eight bucks six bucks
depends on what it is but yeah I'm
really Latino's old man you'd be able to
get that cheap when did that come out
90s 90 yeah four yeah
I want to say I'm not I could be totally
wrong I thought it was 90s though yeah
and if you got Amazon Prime it's free
delivery so you know but yeah I remember
really liking casino but yeah for some
reason like I like American like you
know mob type movies like gangster type
movies but for some reason I like the
British crime movies better I don't know
what it is like I said I guess it's just
like the dialogue like the way they talk
it's like [__] funny
Richard Brown said the weird girl in
terrifier 2 is great yeah I mean I
really liked that movie honestly and
like I said I I kind of feel like people
have been like oh my God it's the
Glorious thing ever I'm like no not
really
it did have some great scenes in it like
the great sequences but I was kind of
expecting it to be like a two-hour
bloodbath and it's really not like that
there was actually like a story and
stuff so I thought that was neat 95 I
was close I was close but yeah so we
might do that uh one of these days too
like I said we still every time we do a
show excuse me every time we do a show I
always think of like five other movies
that it's like oh [__] we haven't
reviewed that one yet either God there's
so many we'll never run out of [__] to
talk about yeah a lot of them are great
Casino was great Goodfellas was great I
can't believe we haven't done good
Fellas yeah like I said I know we did
The Godfather movies because somebody
sent us the Godfather movies yeah um
it was Louie yeah
Louis sent us all three yeah they're
great flicks get them off yeah and I
haven't seen I haven't seen those in a
long time although I agree with whatever
everybody else said three was not the
not the best one I mean uh I don't think
anybody thinks yeah that's the best one
it was okay it was all right though it
was okay the best one was [__]
Godfather 2 actually yeah I think most
people like 99 of people say that yeah
it means [__] the sequel is [__]
better than the Godfather one of the
very very few yeah it was The Empire
Strikes Back cases yeah of gangster
movies gangster movies yeah it was
exactly that yeah exactly that all right
so I guess we're gonna wrap it up so
thank you everybody for dropping by
listen let's talk about this first guy
Richie movie it's great if you haven't
seen it
um so tomorrow
is Monday and uh I have the day off
because woo it's a holiday yeah so we're
doing
um a haunting Mondays and we're gonna do
the next uh episode of season five which
is called The Exorcism of Cindy Sauer is
I guess how you pronounce her last name
s-a-u-e-r yeah I barely remember this
one like I was looking at I was making
the um the thumbnails for it and I saw
like a couple of the stills from it on
IMDb and one of them's crazy like I was
like oh I gotta use that one that's like
[__] hilarious because you have like
[__] crazy eyes and big teeth like
they they did like you remember that
video for um that Soundgarden song Black
Hole Sun where everybody's like [__]
faces were distorted like it looked kind
of like that and I was like oh that's
neat okay so I wanted to use that and
then I was like I kind of remember this
one but we'll watch it tonight and like
see what because we were thinking about
I don't know we were gonna go out
tonight because they're having an extra
Memento Mori but I think we might skip
it because we have all we had a lot of
stuff to do and we had to buy so much
[__] this one well I made like a
clothing haul yeah like I said because
we're gonna be making more videos we got
to make it we gotta shoot another video
another scene tomorrow too
um I have a little bit more editing to
do and we're gonna start putting up
stuff on only fans
um Tom's actually gonna run that account
yeah so we got to get the approval yeah
we've got to get to what do you call it
uh you gotta have your identity has to
be you have to have your picture like
next to your IDs they have to be
confirmed over 18. probably both of us
I did I got it we got an account there
already but it's not a Creator account
so once it becomes a creator you guys
all know about it we'll promote it and
uh
uh we'll start uh selling subscriptions
over there yeah we got a bunch of [__]
like we got a bunch of photos yeah we
got it so we're just gonna start like
parceland stuff out we're gonna start
putting stuff up on there every month
we'll be able to do a couple more videos
and about and more photos every month
yeah but so that's what I did I was like
so I went to Xi'an yesterday and just
picked out like a bunch more outfits
because I think I said on Friday night
that we were actually going to go to
sweethearts
uh to look and see if they had some
clothes and bras and stuff like that and
sweethearts is still there there's
actually two locations which I don't
know but we went there and hadn't been
there in such a long time and I guess
what happened was that they decided that
they were gonna have to go like more
high-end like for specialty type stuff
straight strippers so they still have
stripper clothes and like shoes and
everything like that but now they're
like way expensive everything's 100
bucks everything is like 100 119 like
just for like a strip and I mean they're
nice but yeah they're not that nice but
they're not 119 nice no and they've got
a lot of [__] sequins on them and
[__] glittery very sequining
everything yeah and there's kind of a
Latin flavor to everything that's that's
not what we're looking for so then like
so after we did that and then like we
popped through like Victoria's Secret
and see what they had in there and it's
like they had they had some nice [__] in
there too but again it's like kind of
more like expensive for what it was
overpriced in vanilla so we kind of went
we were just like [__] it so we just
came home and went on she and just
picked
well it was 130 and then I spent 50 uh
Amazon like getting some broth she and
Amazon is really where all the sweat
clothes are yeah Amazon got a good
slight clothes
I spent 130 that's that was with
shipping and everything yeah um and I
got how many outfits Man four or five I
got like five six dresses two more wigs
two wigs a bunch of jewelry a lot of
nice some tights a lot of nice tights
spider web looking tight it's all real
goth looking [__] uh another skirt
accessories a couple gloves like some
gloves yeah cool gloves um I got a [__]
ton of stuff yeah like it easily like
seven eight outfits yeah you can get it
for 130 you get a cute goth mini dress
for 12 bucks I was so mad though because
it's like I had all this [__] in my cart
yeah and then like I tried to pay for it
and I tried to do PayPal and it just
like sat there and looked at me and then
it timed out and it not only timed out
and canceled the order it threw
everything out of the cart and I had to
start completely over again oh my God I
was so mad like Tom is like I'm getting
away from you right now because because
I was getting so frustrated like why
because I hadn't spent so long like
putting oh like finding all that stuff
and putting it all in there and I had it
all done and then like they just threw
it all out of my cart and I had to find
everything over again the sheen app
it's s-h-e-i-e-i-n
if you know how to search man they have
the women's stuff's better than the
men's stuff it's just that's I think
that's true everywhere
you can get close based upon genre not
only do they have goth they have pop
they have fairy core yeah which is
that's a nice [__] in there I got a good
real quick I got a couple dresses from
that section too because I was like oh
that's nice very core if you guys know
what that is it's kind of like goth
mixed with
uh [__]
um hippie kind of yeah it has a lunch a
little hippie grunge like 90s kind of
flavor yeah it's kind of like the stuff
you know uh uh [__] Babes in Toyland
or [__] Mazzy Star was wearing
they're like little yeah like 90s Indie
it's definitely has that kind of flavor
yeah it's nice it's kind of like gothy
looking but then it also has kind of
like butterflies and mushrooms like
earthy type Earth but yeah I got a
couple dresses like along that line that
had like butterflies on it but they
looked kind of like antiquey like the
colors so I thought that was like yeah
but yeah so but that's I mean not bad
130 for he's like six or seven outfits
recommend the sheen app yeah they have
guy stuff there they even have like
military boots but the the price is like
40 bucks for military style you know if
I can uh brown boots
I never haven't tried them I've never
seen those Brands here I don't know if
they're actually mil-spec but they have
a lot of military style stuff in there
uh and camping survival type stuff
whatever they didn't really have good
golf guy goth stuff though it's just
well they probably I mean they probably
don't have as much the customers aren't
they yeah I feel like girls are mostly
it's girls yeah they're like 90 of the
clientele for that yeah Jonas Perkins
said where's the only fans link well
like I said there's nothing on there yet
but what is your name oh okay we may
change the name because right now it's
just called what like Tom and Jen it's
just called Tom and Jan but we're gonna
change that name to something else we're
gonna have links uh to it later yes
because like I said tonight and tomorrow
yeah
um or maybe tomorrow that's one of the
main priorities is we're gonna we have
like a bunch of photos they don't really
need that much touching up because most
of them turned out okay most of them
don't need any touching yeah I don't
think they do um but we're gonna do
um we have like some videos edited but
we're gonna do like little one minute
like teaser Clips like to put up on
there so we're gonna do that too yeah
for a certain amount of tips you want to
tip is 10 20 bucks something like that
then you'll get the full
yeah and like I said we gotta shoot
another scene tomorrow too which we've
already pretty much planned out yeah but
and I'll probably set it up to where
it's like five or six bucks bucks a
month to subscribe so you'll see the
data stream and you'll be able to go in
and tip and give suggestions and buy
things you know it'll be like that I
think well once once the Creator count
starts I'll see if there are different
kind of formats that I can run it in I
don't know if I could have like a menu
where you can go in and just buy videos
or we'll see we'll see yeah we'll figure
it out yeah but yeah we're definitely
gonna that's gonna be the main priority
but you're not gonna have access to free
full-length [__] 15 20 half hour
videos it's not gonna be like that at
first because we have some that are like
20 minutes yeah and you have to sell
those you know I mean you can't just
give them away on a subscription
but we will have Clips but there'll be
stuff in there yeah we all have clips of
them that you can watch though yeah like
that are shorter we'll see we'll see how
it is yeah depends on how long this
stuff if it's not that long then maybe
we'll put it up five minutes six minutes
maybe we can put that in there for free
because we do have some stuff like that
yeah so it'll be a cheap subscription
and for if you want more you got to pay
a little bit more we'll give you like a
free video or something yeah and we're
gonna keep doing it like I said we'll
just do the video but we'll sell you a
video but we'll just post photos and
videos like I said Tom's gonna run it
like the social media thing and so like
I can just like send him photos and from
what I've seen so far it kind of runs
like it kind of runs like Facebook
yeah where you just have a feed and you
can put you drop stuff in it right it's
like Facebook but like x-rated yeah like
you can put whatever you want like in
your feed but not but only people that
subscribe to you can see it yeah so it's
not like in public or anything yeah Jen
doesn't really have time to run it
yeah so I was really happy when he said
today he's like well yeah I can feel I
can run it and I was like well that's
good because yeah [__] if you guys
are regulars of this show
if you want to talk to her you just talk
to her here at a live stream you don't
need only fans to talk to her that's
just to see her
yeah yeah
you know uh all right so I guess we're
gonna wrap it up like I said tomorrow
we're doing a haunting we might do it
should we do it earlier or should we do
it at 7 30 like usual what's that the um
The Haunting show because you normally
we would do it at 7 30 because I'd be
working no you can do it earlier and get
it out of the way but we can do it early
maybe we'll do it at six like yeah today
because I'll be home yeah we might even
be able to do it earlier than that
because if you want to get it out of the
way because yeah production stuff we can
do yeah that's true because we might go
do it in the afternoon people won't care
it's a holiday I mean I'll announce it
because yeah just whenever it is because
I actually did already like make a
teaser thing for it and like scheduled
it but I can change that people in other
countries might appreciate it it might
be a bit more better for their time zone
yeah that's true all right so we will
see you guys again tomorrow uh to talk
about some ghosts and [__] like that or
possession I guess is the one we're
gonna watch so thanks everybody for
dropping by and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow bye